wohnen mieten kaufen fonds themen
unserer zeit menschen können sich die
mieten nicht mehr leisten ein eigenheim
für unsere generation oft undenkbar ich
finde es einfach ungerecht dass wir uns
hier in den stadtteil einfach keine
andere wohnung leisten kann um den
wohnungsmarkt zu entlasten will die
bundesregierung bauen 400.000 neue
wohnungen sollen pro jahr gebaut werden
können
doch die städte kommen nicht voran dabei
gibt es die grundstücke in bester lage
doch anstatt sie zu bebauen werden hier
millionen verdient ich wundere mich dass
hier so ein monopoly passiert und das
ist einfach nur dazu benutzt um geld zu
verdienen wir folgen der spur des geldes
recherchieren zwei beispiele
stellvertretend für die misere wir
erhalten einblick in kaufverträge und
zeichnen die dimension eines geschäfts
dass in unseren städten täglich passiert
aber oft verborgen bleibt der bodenpreis
dort hat sich für 60 konfrontieren eine
der umtriebigsten bauunternehmer
deutschlands mit seinen geschäften ich
bin spät gelang nach den regeln der
sozialen marktwirtschaft und wir fragen
wieso die politik die bau giganten
machen lässt und zuschaut wie wenige im
land immer reicher werden während wir
uns das wohnen nicht mehr leisten können
[Musik]
unsere recherche beginnt in leipzig
statt immer mehr menschen ziehen hierher
wir leben hier und merken die mieten
explodieren freunde müssen umziehen es
wird immer schwerer eine wohnung zu
finden umso erstaunlicher mitten in
leipzig liegt dieses riesengelände seit
jahren brach
eigentlich soll ja ein neues
stadtviertel entstehen mit platz für
über 3000 menschen früher waren hier
betriebe nachts konnte man tanzen gehen
also hier war eine komplette gebäude
reihe wo der klub auch drin war
eigentlich ein seestück versteck auch
abzutragen
aber ich meine das ist noch kein
einziges haus entstanden
die deutsche bahn hat den ehemaligen
güterbahnhof 2005 verkauft ich habe so
ein paar satelliten fotos und jetzt
gucken was passiert ist hier so die
letzten jahre 2006 beispielsweise liegen
noch die schienen
die bilder zeigen in den vergangenen 15
jahren wurden die schienen abgetragen
und häuser abgerissen
viel hat sich ihnen nicht getan und das
ärgert auch die die hier leben
wir räumen nach wie vor nur drei
schwimmer karte sieht wir haben auch
gehört dass die firma täters
ursprünglich entwickelt hat das wohl
weiter verkauft hat liest du musst dort
gebauten schulen eine campus oktober das
soll das team ist ökologisch alles
gemacht werden mit grünen dächern mit
wasserrückhaltebecken aber hier tut sich
nichts und im endeffekt das tutorial
werden das ist überhaupt können wir
eine miete leisten kann obwohl hier noch
nicht gebaut wurde soll sich der preis
der brache verzehnfacht haben leipzig
ist nur ein beispiel von vielen das
zeigt dass sie etwas extrem schief läuft
bodenpreise steigen seit jahren in ganz
deutschland schauen wir hier gerade die
zahlen aus den vergangenen jahrzehnten
an und das ist schon ziemlich krass
anfang der 60er jahre kostete ein
quadratmeter bauland in deutschland noch
sieben euro 60 seitdem steigt der preis
mit wenigen ausnahmen auf fast 200 euro
im jahr 2020 besonders heftig sind die
preise seit ungefähr 2010 explodiert und
es betrifft offenbar vor allen dingen
die großen städte in leipzig hat sich
der bodenpreis in zehn jahren
verfünffacht auf
466 euro pro quadratmeter in anderen
städten sind die preise noch höher zum
teil über 1000 euro in frankfurt berlin
oder hamburg zum beispiel das ist mehr
als fünfmal so viel wie im
bundesdurchschnitt
spitzenreiter ist münchen
dort liegt der preis im schnitt sogar
bei über 2500 euro ich frage mich jetzt
wieso gehen diese preise so nach oben
dafür spreche ich mit jemandem der seit
jahren zu geschäft mit dem boden forscht
professor dirk löhr von ihm will ich
wissen wie es boden so lukrativ geworden
so richtig dynamisch geworden ist die
ganze geschichte eigentlich erst seit
der wirtschaftskrise 2008 2009 wo dann
auch die zinsentwicklung deutlich nach
unten gezeigt hat und die leute einfach
in bauland gegangen sind mit niedrigen
zinsen wurde ist günstig sich geld zu
leihen viele investierten in sichere
anlagen wie bauland die nachfrage stieg
wer boden besitzt verdient seitdem
vermietet sagt auf drauf wohnen ist eine
riesige
umverteilungsmaschine es gibt leute die
können sich in der nach hinlegen
schlafengehen am nächsten tag sehr
reicher haben nichts geleistet das ist
schlicht und ergreifend
etwas was man eigentlich im mittelalter
angenommen hätte mit voll gesellschaft
aber nicht mehr bei uns aber trotzdem
wir haben es immer noch es ist nicht so
modern gewesen
boden als gesellschaftlicher sprengstoff
mit der konsequenz dass wir uns das
alles nicht mehr leisten können in
hamburg haben sich die preise in zehn
jahren fast verdreifacht
was bedeutet das für die menschen
rio würde gerne mit ihrem partner und
zwei kindern aus der dreizimmerwohnung
in eine größere wohnung ziehen
man kann man erst mal der wunsch auf
sich zu vergrößern mit dem gedanken
würden wir noch ein kind haben wollen ja
nein
natürlich ja auch irgendwie wohnfläche
dafür auch mit zwei kindern kann man
auch gut in der drei zimmer wohnung
wurden drei kinder leer nicht mehr man
wird auch von den eltern und großeltern
immer wieder gefragt wann zieht ihr denn
in eine größere wohnung und wollte ich
euch nicht ein haus bauen ja selber
bauen wäre schön aber die preise in
hamburg und umgebung sind fast
unbezahlbar wir schauen uns aktuelle
immobilienangebote an
eines wird auch wieder junge besonders
auf
850.000 mit den stadtteiltreff
weil es eigentlich eher zu den
günstigeren stadtteilen gehört find's
einfach erschreckend was den kaufpreis
das ist auch eine eigentumswohnung in
der nachbarschaft scheint unmöglich
obwohl sie und ihr partner als
verwaltungsangestellte und zimmermann
eigentlich gut verdienen
ich finde es einfach ungerecht wir
arbeiten viel wir arbeiten beide fast
vollzeit haben gute jobs aber trotzdem
ist es nicht wissen
wie sie können sich immer weniger der 30
bis 44 jährigen die zur miete leben
wohneigentum leisten
ihr anteil hat sich in zehn jahren
halbiert von 8,7 auf nur 4,8 prozent der
traum vom eigenheim für unsere
generation ist er ausgeträumt dabei gäbe
es den platz sowie auf einem gelände
direkt bei ihr um die ecke es ist so
groß wie zwei fußballfelder und liegt
mitten in altona einem beliebten viertel
der hansestadt schon jetzt liegt die
miete in der umgebung mit rund 13 euro
deutlich über dem hamburger durchschnitt
auch auf diesem gelände soll vor allem
geld verdient worden sein das
unternehmen carlsberg hat hier lange
eine brauerei betrieben
2016 verkauft ist das gelände dann an
die gategroup dort kaufvertrag für knapp
152 millionen euro
dann gab es mehrere verkäufe und
übernahmen heute gehört das gelände der
adler laut quartalsbericht ist es jetzt
364 millionen euro wert
der wehr und hat sich mehr als
verdoppelt dabei ist er eigentlich noch
nicht viel passiert außer dass
abgerissen wurde im haus steht hier noch
nicht das scheint auch noch ein bisschen
zu dauern bis das erste haus zu gebaut
wird hohe mieten werden hier erwartet
und das könnte folgen für das ganze
viertel haben das befürchtet auch eine
anwohnerin
wir haben einen wunderbaren blick auf
die baustelle
sie ist direkt neben unserem balkon
und bagger man jetzt hört ist erleben
gerade die tanks der rena wurde wohnt
mit ihrem mann und ihrer tochter seit 16
jahren in diesem haus bis zu 20 euro pro
quadratmeter könnte die miete auf dem
holsten gelände betragen das liegt über
dem mietspiegel und könnte auch bei ihr
die miete in die höhe treiben mehr als
jetzt sagt kann sie sich nicht leisten
doch wegziehen ist keine option
wohnen allein ist ja nichts das mobile
zimmer sondern wir haben hier unsere
freunde unsere tochter ist jetzt der
schule gegangen sie hat ihre clique
aufgebaut die leute ziehen ja nicht alle
mit ich habe mich hier eingelebt ich
möchte nicht so schnell wieder weg bevor
hier wohnen bleiben ich möchte hier
wohnen bleiben und ich möchte es mir
leisten können
hallo jonas ich komme aus dem gespräch
mit la vista wurde eine anwohnerin wir
hatten ziemlich guten blick auf das
gelände und die hat richtig angst dass
das ganze areal eigentlich nur ein
luxusbau wird das sagt er und ist nicht
mit der april konfrontieren wir die
unternehmen mit den vorwürfen keine
spekulation sondern ein üblicher vorgang
bei projektentwicklungen schreibt die
adler group
dass der wert höher liegt als 1 5 jahre
zufolge zahlt der kaufpreis ergibt sich
dadurch dass das projekt in der
zwischenzeit weiter geplant und
entwickelt wurde
aber lässt sich so die verdoppelung
erklären die gategroup die das gelände
ursprünglich von der brauerei gekauft
hatte schreibt der vorgang auf dem
holsten areal habe mit dem eigentlichen
geschäftsmodell wenig zu tun sondern ist
vollkommen anders gelagert und stellt
einen eher außergewöhnlichen
geschäftsvorgang da der strategisch
begründet war
mit dem verkauf von unternehmensanteilen
sei auch das grundstück weiterverkauft
worden wie hoch der gewinn war wird uns
nicht mitgeteilt die anderen unternehmen
antworten gar nicht
leipzig hamburg zwei beispiele die
stellvertretend für ganz deutschland
stehen unternehmen machen mit den
steigenden bodenpreisen profite in dem
sie bauland kaufen wenig tun wieder
verkaufen und damit geld verdienen also
ich finde es schon ziemlich erstaunlich
dass das einfach immer wieder passiert
schon vor über 50 jahren beschäftigte
sich das bundesverfassungsgericht damit
der grund und boden ist wie der
volkswirtschaftlich noch in seiner
sozialen bedeutung mit anderen
vermögenswerten gleichzustellen
boden sei keine waage wie jede andere
das gericht hatte damals aber abgewogen
das gemeinwohl gegen das recht auf
eigentum und hat am ende festgestellt
das geschäft mit dem boden zu verbieten
dinge auch nicht
und das geschäft floriert weiß andré
adami berater von immobilienunternehmen
er sagt oft ist es lukrativer
grundstücke weiter zu verkaufen anstatt
sie zu bebauen die entwicklung in den
städten war insbesondere den letzten 58
jahren sehr dynamisch so dass also diese
gewinnmargen die einfach nur durch den
grundstückshandel möglich waren
überproportional bahn das kennen wir aus
dem vorjahr nicht es hat sich auch
teilweise als geschäftsmodell entwickelt
ja das gibt den englischen begriff des
land bankings dass ich also speziell
wirklichen grundstücke ankaufen um sie
ein stück weit entweder nur zu halten
oder auch ein stück weit zu entwickeln
dass
ist ja ein neuer prozess der in
deutschland eingesetzt hat besonders
gewinnbringend sei die umwidmung von
geländen in bauland
ich kann in der regel grundstücke
einkaufen die haben als gewerbeland mal
ursprünglich 50 100 euro gekostet und
allein in dem moment wo ich also einen
bebauungsplan aufstellen für wohnbauland
verdreifacht vervierfacht 85 der preis
das ist also durchaus üblich für adamy
ist es allerdings absolut
nachvollziehbar das unternehmen
größtmögliche gewinne machen wollen er
findet der eigentliche fehler liege bei
den städten da muss man ganz ehrlich
sagen dass es in den letzten zehn 15
jahren prozesse gab wo also die
stadtentwicklung die städte selbst
eingeschlafen haben sie haben also sind
eher als grundstücksverkäufer an den an
den plan getreten aus analystensicht aus
gutachter sich tim b es empfehlenswert
gewesen als stadt selbst grundstücke zu
entwickeln und das nicht den projekt den
privaten projektentwickler
ausschließlich zu überlassen kann es
sein dass die städte jahrelang
zugeschaut haben während unternehmen
profite machten um herauszufinden ob das
stimmt schicken wir fragen an die 80
größten städte in deutschland wir wollen
wissen wie viel boden sie selbst
besitzen wie konsequent greifen sie
einen das geschäft mit dem boden wie
sehr haben sie das problem überhaupt auf
dem schirm
während ich auf die ergebnisse warten
blicke ich noch einmal auf das areal in
leipzig laut zeitungsberichten soll sich
der wert der brache verzehnfacht haben
wir finden heraus tatsächlich sind die
deals noch lukrativer gewesen über das
grundbuch erhalten wir einblick in
bislang unbekannte dokumente die eine
neue dimension der geschäfte zeigen
das war ein ziemlicher aufriss ich habe
dutzende kaufverträge dafür einsehen
müssen aber wir haben jetzt die verträge
und jetzt geht es darum einmal
nachzuzeichnen wer hat das wan besessen
und wie war die preisentwicklung
die deutsche bahn hält das areal ist
2005 dann kaufte die vermögensverwaltung
vvb capital ag einen großen teil der
brache für 2,1 millionen euro
ab 2015 stieg ein projektentwickler ece
gruppe ein und kaufte für rund 33
millionen euro grundstücke auf dem
gelände
2019 dann der nächste verkauf im fall
kaufte die gesamte fläche für 195
millionen euro
2021 wurde bekannt dass die gateway real
estate ag auf der brache einsteigt das
gelände soll jetzt 210 millionen euro
wert sein
ok also im jahr 2005 beim ersten verkauf
war der boden zehn euro pro quadratmeter
wert im jahr
2021 ist der boden über 600 euro pro
quadratmeter wert man kann also sagen
der bodenpreis dort hat sich mal locker
60 wacht der bodenpreis der brache liegt
damit schon jetzt über dem leipziger
durchschnitt von fast 470 euro
wir schreiben die unternehmen an wollen
wissen wie konnten sie so viele
millionen mit dem leipziger boden machen
einer erklärt sich zum interview bereit
[Musik]
christoph gröner mit der c gruppe hat er
laut unserer rechnung den höchsten
gewinn auf der brache eingefahren der
immobilientycoon ist einer von
deutschlands superreichen geschätztes
vermögen 80 millionen euro hamburg
berlin köln münchen grüna hat
bauprojekte in praktisch allen großen
städten deutschlands und profitiert von
der marktentwicklung wie in leipzig umso
mehr wundern wir uns darüber dass er
öffentlich immer wieder gegen das
geschäft mit dem boden wettert
sieht er sich etwa selbst als opfer der
spekulation
der termin findet in berlin statt in der
firmenzentrale seines neuen unternehmens
auch mehr erklärt er weshalb
spekulationen der branche schwer
zusetzen oft kommt es inzwischen vor
dass etwas entsteht oder gar nicht mehr
entsteht weil niemand mehr da ist der
lead hohen preise bezahlen kann und dann
bleibt das projekt stecken wie häufig
passiert ist ich würde sagen in zwei
drittel bis drei viertel das hatten wir
sind doch in deutschland in der
situation dass wir nicht mit
vernünftigen preisen in jeder stadt
bauen können wenn sie nach leipzig gehen
sind die grundstückspreise so
abgekoppelt von dem was die kaufkraft in
der stadt kann dass ich niemanden kenne
der dort ernsthaft noch investiert und
deswegen ist die spekulation ganz sicher
unser feind jedem der mittelstand
schenkt jedem der in deutschland oder
mitteleuropa tätig werden möchte ist der
steige land einen dorn im auge weil er
uns quasi die lebensgrundlage aber es
haben sehr eben selber gesagt dass die
aufstockung sind ich bin spekulant nach
den regeln der sozialen marktwirtschaft
er verdiene geld indem er grundstücke
weiterentwicklung
unterm strich habe mit dem verkauf der
brache 60 millionen euro gewinn gemacht
das rechnet er uns sogar vor
im geschäfts deutsch heißt das lucky die
lacke deal ist wenn ich das grundstück
das sich seinerzeit für diese 33
millionen kaufte hat wahrscheinlich viel
mehr wert
die die es verkauft haben ein
professioneller grundstückskäufer die
sich nicht darüber bewusst waren
kaufleute aus leipzig wenn ich habe das
glück gehabt dass viel zu günstig zu
kriegen deswegen ist der gewinn später
möglich geworden er hätte gerne gebaut
verkauft habe er nur weil ihm die stadt
kein baurecht erteilt habe naja aber sie
haben es ja gerade selber bestätigt dass
es in dem fall ja das lukrativere
geschäft war ich habe das lukrative
geschäft auch nicht gemacht weil ich ein
lukratives geschäft dann wird uns das
geschäftsmodell eines unternehmens ist
doch grundstück zu kaufen zu bauen und
nur in dem fall in dem die kommune ihre
verpflichtungen nicht hält habe ich mich
aus der notsituation befreit und haben
aus versehen dabei ein gutes geschäft
gemacht entschuldigung dass ich dabei
auch noch ein gutes geschäft gemacht hat
und nicht noch verdient haben weil mir
die grundstückspreise also die
grundstücksentwicklung entgegenkommen
wir fragen die stadt leipzig an doch die
will uns kein interview vor der kamera
geben stattdessen bekommen wir diese
antwort richtig ist dass eine ganze
reihe von voraussetzungen für die
erteilung von baurechts und zeitpunkt
des verkaufs nicht erfüllt waren deshalb
habe kein baurecht erteilt werden können
grüner beschuldigt die stadt die stadt
weist die schuld von sich hier kommen
wir nicht weiter
die gateway real estate der aktuelle
eigentümer der brache schickt gemeinsam
mit dem vorbesitzer impfe ein statement
die bereits erfolgten transaktionen der
vergangenheit projekte und
möglicherweise aus spekulativen gründen
und haben grund und boden belastet wie
bereits erläutert ist die motivation der
imker und der gateway eine andere
fest steht mit der brache wird seit
jahren geld verdient und noch immer ist
kein einziges haus entstanden immer
wieder haben wir mit menschen gesprochen
die uns erzählen sich das wohnen nicht
mehr leisten zu können grüner findet das
liege nicht an den geschäften der
immobilienwirtschaft erfüllt berlin als
beispiel an
bemerkenswert ist dass wir dass wir hier
umstände vorfinden die nicht ausreichend
um menschen in die lage zu versetzen
sich adäquat teuren wohnraum zu leisten
das ist nicht ein problem der
immobilienwirtschaft preise sind nicht
zu teuer sondern die leute sind zu arm
dass die in der breite inzwischen
gestiegenen mieten für viele existenzen
zu hoch aber nein das liegt nicht daran
dass die immobilieninvestoren versuchen
eine riesen rendite zu machen sondern es
liegt darin dass wir eine verwerfung
haben zwischen der möglichkeit sich eine
wohnung zu leisten und zwischen der
notwendigkeit minimum mieten zu nehmen
um eine ein gebäude im laufen zu halten
ende märz bin ich noch einmal mit
oregano in hamburg verabredet
hier demonstriert sie mit einer
initiative gegen die geschäfte auf dem
holz na wer
dahin laufen sich schon mit
flaschen in anlehnung an das holzlager
was wir mal eine brauerei war die
initiative fordert dass die
bezirksregierung den sogenannten
städtebaulichen vertrag mit dem
aktuellen grundstücksbesitzer adler
group nicht unterschreibt und die sache
selbst in die hand nimmt
unser wunsch wäre dass es sozusagen
wieder zurück in die stadt geht in
städtischen hände das wäre natürlich das
beste wenn der vertrag eigentlich gar
nichts zustande kommt und das ganze
kommunalisiert wird jaja und ihren
mitstreitern ist klar dass das einen
möglichen bau verzögern würde sie nehmen
das aber in kauf und den luxus baum auf
dem areal zu verhindern auch theo bruns
ist in der initiative er kritisiert die
hamburger statt politik ganz grundlegend
und wir sagen ja auch das holz la real
ist praktisch das paradebeispiel für das
komplette scheitern
dieses modells von profitorientierter
stadt entwicklungen die initiative ist
optimistisch habt ihr das gefühl hier
könnt ihr was bewirken ich hab' ich
glaube schon also ich glaube dass hier
schon gefällt sich jetzt google sorgt
der aktuelle besitzer des holzmann
areals die adler group steckt derzeit in
der krise seit monaten wird diskutiert
wie zahlungsfähig ist der konzern es
geht jetzt nicht mehr nur noch darum wie
hoch die mieten werden sondern auch
darum ob das unternehmen überhaupt in
der lage ist das grundstück zu bebauen
genau die wollen den städtebaulichen
vertrag
die unterschrift verhindern aber
irgendwie die hoffnung dass sie da noch
irgendwas
im reißen können hat die stadt beim
holzen areal nicht hart genug
durchgegriffen anfang april verabrede
ich mich mit bausenatorin dorothee
stapelfeldt sie ist für die
entwicklungen auf dem holsten areal
politisch verantwortlich und sie gibt zu
die voraussichtlichen mieten auf dem
gelände sind zu hoch es gibt ja einen
städtebaulichen vertrag der entworfen
worden ist der von dem jetzigen
eigentümer des areals schon
unterschrieben ist und im frei
finanzierten bereich des wohnungsneubaus
mieten aufruft die für uns eigentlich
schwer akzeptabel sind hinzu kämen die
turbulenzen beim investor adler group
eine zusammenarbeit stehe deshalb in
frage
2016 hätte die stadt das gelände per
vorkaufsrecht selbst kaufen können sie
hat laut eintrag im grundbuchamt darauf
verzichtet
wenn sie jetzt von heute aus heutiger
sicht auf das gelände gucken war das
thema das die stadt das damals nicht
gekauft hat also es ist bitter zu sehen
wie solche entwicklung laufen und das
macht man sicherlich auch kein zweites
mal halten doch plötzlich ein paar
wochen später veröffentlichte investor
eine umstrittene jahresbilanz nun drückt
die stadt tatsächlich ob sie das gelände
selbst kauft doch ob das geht und wenn
ja zu welchem preis ist völlig unklar
doch insgesamt setzt man in hamburg auf
das bauen um die hohen mieten in den
griff zu bekommen und in der tat
entstehen in hamburg mehr neue wohnungen
als in anderen deutschen metropolen aber
geht der plan auf entsteht bezahlbarer
wohnraum wenn die bodenpreise so hoch
sind ich bin mit jemandem verabredet der
in hamburg eigentlich günstig bauen will
thomas cook leitet die genossenschaft
altova guten tag herr gruber gut sagen
was vielleicht so nicht machen
in hamburg sind knapp ein fünftel aller
wohnungen in der hand von
genossenschaften
bundesweit ein relativ hoher wert
das ziel einer genossenschaft ihre
mitglieder mit günstigem wohnraum zu
versorgen
wie hoch ist der andrang auf ihre
genossenschaft wie lange sind die
wartelisten ja wir haben die große
nachfrage nach den wohnungen in hall
thomas schaaf wir haben
ja quasi listen für unsere mitglieder
und genährt dass die nachfrage nach
wohnraum zimmern der besonders stark
hier auf coopers baustelle entstehen
viele geförderte wohnungen für sechs
euro 60 pro quadratmeter noch im mai
sollen hier die ersten mieter einziehen
wir stehen als genossenschaften auch im
wettbewerb mit anderen akteuren wo
losgesagt und können ob die preise im
zweifel gar nicht mehr mitgehen die hier
aufgerufen werde sicher sehr besorgt
dass wir in hamburg auch künftig
überhaupt noch grundstück befinden aus
dem wir zu guten konditionen wohnungsbau
generieren rupert eine beispielrechnung
mitgebracht oft kostet der quadratmeter
wohnfläche 2000 euro das führe zu einer
miete von gut 12 euro
pro weiteren 500 euro steigt auch die
miete um 50 cent
da muss jetzt wollen mal angeguckt
was wird hier auch pro quadratmeter
bezahlt und das sind spitzenwerte aber
es denn werte die hier bezahlt werden
das dann durchaus auch 10.000 euro pro
quadratmeter wohnfläche weise die 10.000
euro den quadratmeter wohnfläche wir als
genossenschaft nicht mehr mithalten aber
sie können sich noch mal einen geben wir
schauen uns die auswirkungen
20 euro 20 euro kaltmiete den
quadratmeter ja wenn man sie vermieten
würde würde würde man bei solchen
mietpreisen dann exakt wie eine 80
quadratmeter wohnung werden das 1600
euro kaltmiete unvorstellbar für eine
genossenschaft die sich verpflichtet hat
wirklich günstig zu vermieten huber geht
davon aus dass in zukunft deutlich
weniger gebaut wird die bodenpreise sind
hoch und seit einiger zeit steigen auch
noch die baukosten
umso mehr hoffen die menschen in hamburg
dass die stadt gelände wie das holz
areal selbst kauft und entwickelt eine
möglichkeit mehr kontrolle über boden
bau und mieten zu erhalten wie läuft das
in anderen städten wir haben ja die 80
größten städte in deutschland gefragt
was tut ihr eigentlich gegen die
steigende bodenpreise und wie viel boden
gehört euch eigentlich in eurer stadt
nach einigen wochen sind die antworten
da
was uns besonders auffällt viele städte
scheinen das gar nicht zu wissen 41 von
80 angefragten städten antworten nicht
machen keine angaben oder weichen der
frage aus
der durchschnitt bei den städten die uns
geantwortet haben liegt bei 9,2 prozent
aber die werte sind sehr unterschiedlich
salzgitter zum beispiel besitzt nur 0,7
prozent seiner wohnfläche duisburg
dagegen rund 21 prozent hamburg liegt
mit 13 prozent im durchschnitt von
leipzig erhalten wir auf diese frage
keine antwort die ergebnisse die haben
wir auch professor löhr gesteckt und mit
dem wir nicht jetzt verabredet und bin
schon gespannt was seiner einschätzung
dazu ist ich will wissen wie verheerend
ist die lage viele kommunen haben
deutlich zu wenig eigentum in der tasche
hat offensichlich in der vergangenheit
versilbert und hat jetzt nichts mehr man
kann nicht mehr das steuern was auf dem
eigenen beritt stattfindet da sind die
hände der stadt gebunden bei einem ganz
zentralen politikfeld auf dem sie
agieren können offensichtlich wissen
auch viele städte gar nicht was mit
ihren grundstücken auf ihrem brett
geschieht das ist ein ganz zentraler
vermögens wer hat den sie da haben und
sie wissen nicht wie viel haben
überhaupt was ist es wert und so weiter
und so fort also insoweit ist das schon
erschreckend sind sich die städte im
klaren darüber jetzt hier verabredet mit
helmut dedy vom deutschen städtetag die
vertreten die interessen der kommunen in
deutschland und den will ich fragen ob
die kommunen da wirklich was verschlafen
haben helmut dedy räumt fehler ein
die städte haben in teilen in den
letzten 10 20 jahren auch grundstücke
verkauft und teilweise um den haushalt
zu sanieren teilweise vielleicht auch
aus purer not
rückblickend betrachtet würde ich sagen
so ganz klug war das nicht viele städte
wollten sich aus der situation befreien
und boden an kaufen sagte die oft
fehlten aber das geld und vor allem
effektive werkzeuge
die müsse der bund liefern die
bundesregierung hat eine eigene
ministerin ernannt klara geywitz
400.000 wohnungen will sie pro jahr
bauen und scheint das problem auf dem
schirm zu haben
dagegen dem grundstück bei den einzelnen
auf wertsteigerung spekulieren können
wir uns nicht mehr leisten
reicht es aus was die bundesregierung
unternimmt also erstmal ist es gut dass
das ein eigenes bauministerium gibt aber
mir fehlt noch die klare botschaft wo
sie eigentlich hinwollen wir wollen den
bau ministerin gallwitz über die
forderung der städte sprechen aber ein
interview kommt nicht zustande das
ministerium schreibt die städte hätten
bereits viele instrumente für eine
gemeinwohlorientierte bodenpolitik das
einzig konkrete gesetzesvorhaben eine
verbesserung des vorkaufsrechts für
städte in besonders angespannten
stadtquartieren selbst das ist in der
koalition umstritten
dem städtetag gibt es nicht weit genug
es bräuchte ein allgemeines
vorkaufsrecht ohne beschränkung auf
bestimmte gebiete um wieder
handlungsfähig zu werden
die grundsätzliche frage ist will ich
dafür sorgen dass der wohnungsbau nicht
dazu beiträgt den sozialen zusammenhalt
in diesem land kaputt zu machen und will
ich deshalb dafür sorgen dass es mehr
gemeinwohlorientierung im wohnungsbau
gibt
explodierende bodenpreise während
konzerne die gewinne einfahren können
sich viele das wohnen nicht mehr leisten
verlierer ist vor allem unsere
generation die politik muss handeln
damit städte wieder steuern können was
auf ihren flächen passiert mit mehr geld
und einem wirklich umfassenden
vorkaufsrecht wir alle müssen wohnen
solange wir den boden aber wie eine
x-beliebige ware behandeln bleibt
wohnraum ein milliarden-geschäft auf das
viele spekulieren mit wenigen gewinnern
und wie diesen verlieren
[Musik]